buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación yo creo que era un primer
tiempo hay que el dato no lo más
importante es en esa elección es el 28
por ciento de alrededor del 28 por
ciento es que es el plazo de abstención
uno de las más altas desde 1969 y eso
muestra el desinterés de una parte del
electorado y también el rechazo a elegir
entre los dos finalistas y eso yo creo
que mostró también que la elección no
fue como las últimas elecciones para
regresar a su pregunta su pregunta yo
creo que hay que ver que marín efe en
que se presentó tres veces ha tenido una
trayectoria increíble o sea desde 2012
donde perdió fue a cabo como en tercer
puesto y ahora ha tenido más votos
también porque hay un rechazo de esta
política el de sus últimos años esta
cólera donde el presidente macro dijo en
su discurso que él iba y le entendió y
va justamente cambiar cambiar cambiar
las cosas y qué no es un campo pero
llamó a la unidad y yo creo que es un
análisis yo creo importante de entender
que el marido penn también ha moderado
también lo dispuesto y es quizás por eso
también que ha tenido más votantes que
en 2017 y tal como se lo decía esta
abstención es la más alta desde la
segunda vuelta de
1969 y a esa abstención que representa
un hartazgo con la política tradicional
se une una victoria histórica para la
madre indepen tal como usted lo decía
antes de estos dos panoramas entonces
que puede hacer en manuel marco para
garantizar una gobernabilidad en los
próximos cinco años
yo creo que hay una elección que viene
que es muy importante le mostraron en su
reportaje que es el 12 y 19 de junio que
va a mostrar cómo y de qué forma que
creo que es la pregunta que todo el
mundo se hace en francés con qué fuerzas
políticas macro va a constituir una
mayoría de diputados
llevando que hay para tener la mayoría
hay que tener más de 289 escaños de la
asamblea nacional entonces eso es un
reto muy importante para la mujer de
manuel macro y también garantizar
también todo lo que prometió también en
su programa porque lo recordamos que
también en la cólera que hubo en los
chalecos amarillos en la revuelta en la
revuelva de los chalecos amarillos y
también en los rusos en la pandemia hubo
muchas críticas pero al final en manuel
macro poco antes las elecciones eligió
de poner medidas para salir de esta de
esta crisis y esto creo que fue aceptado
bastante bien en francia entonces
con entre la guerra en ucrania y también
las elecciones hay que ver como las
fuerzas políticas empresas se van a
organizar sí y sobre todo el partido de
la república de marcha para tener una
mayoría de diputados en la asamblea
nacional